a dutch court has ordered oil giant
shell to cut its carbon emissions by
nearly 50 percent by 2030.
greenpeace and friends of the earth
brought the case and it's being hailed
as a major victory for environmentalists
shell unsuccessfully argued that
governments not
companies are responsible for meeting
targets under the paris climate deal
the dutch verdict could have major
implications for similar cases
around the world let's go live now to
the hague al jazeera step varsan is
there step what does this mean for shell
well this is seen as a really as a
landmark ruling there was an
outburst of joy here earlier in the
court when the verdict was read out
even some people were in tears a cake is
going around
seven organizations environmental groups
and 17
000 dutch citizens have filed this case
and there was of
of course some optimism that they could
win this case because the same court had
ruled two years earlier against the
dutch state a similar kind of
verdict but of course when the verdict
was actually read they were
so so joyful i'm actually joined here
now by
climate law expert laura burgess who
will give us some more insights into the
this ruling uh thank you for joining us
what does this
important ruling now mean well of course
we have only
here uh heard the judge reading a
summary we didn't read the judgment yet
but we can safely say
it's a groundbreaking judgment and what
it does mean is that shell has a legal
obligation
to do its share against climate change
so uh human rights here are at stake can
you explain
what that yes so indeed against the
dutch state in 2002
in 2018 and 2020 2019
the court here in the hague said that
the dutch state can violate human rights
by
not doing enough against climate change
so that
human rights can be impacted by
dangerous climate change was already
sort of you know set in stone
um but now that these human rights
obligations equally apply to private
entities such as shell that is actually
quite groundbreaking and what does that
mean does shell have to completely
overhaul its business now for
20 30 because they have to cut 45 nearly
half of their emissions
exactly so the court said that in 2030
2030 a shell has to cut 45 percent of
its emissions
compared to the year 2019 and not only
has shelter got its own emissions
but it also must do its best to reduce
emissions
of uh its consumers using shells
projects products so including people
driving cars
uh exactly getting gasoline yes exactly
so they have to go
completely renewable then in a very
short period of time well that is likely
the court said it's not an obligation
of absolute emission reduction so they
can also compensate perhaps
um in a way so that it's nets
a net reduction in the ends we're
talking now about shell but what could
this mean for other companies oil
companies around the world
well i think we can safely assume that
shell will appeal this judgment
but the judgement is already binding so
even though it will appeal it has to act
on it and that means that it's very
likely that other such cases will arise
are there any sanctions i mean how can a
court enforce these kind of rulings
yes so um a court can then put penalties
if
shell is not yeah living up to this
judgment
thank you very much we have we have yet
to hear from michelle
the lawyers just left the court as soon
as the verdict
was read out they have promised some
kind of response and as
laura berger said we are expecting them
of course to appeal and maybe also
friends of the earth and all the
environmental groups
will appeal because some issues were not
uh
clarified yes just yet so this case
isn't over yet but
of course everyone who has filed this
case is very very cheerful now
al jazeera step faster reporting live
from the hague step
thanks